[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
MALE SPEAKER: Welcome
to Google I/O.
We live in very,
very exciting times.
Computing has had an
amazing evolution.
So leveraging our
state-of-the-art capabilities
in machine learning and AI,
we truly want to take the next
step in being more
assistive for our users.
MALE SPEAKER: Our
aspiration is to make
the assistant
useful and enjoyable
in one of the most important
places in your world,
where you spend time
with your family.
MALE SPEAKER: We're thinking
about evolving our products,
and a key driver is Android.
With the N release, we
wanted to achieve a new level
of product excellence.
FEMALE SPEAKER: We're evolving
Android apps to run instantly,
without installation.
MALE SPEAKER: With
Android Wear 2.0,
we're evolving the platform to
build even better experiences
for the watch base,
messaging, and fitness.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Android
Studio is our official IDE.
92% of the top 125 apps
now use Android Studio.
MALE SPEAKER:
Software developers
are changing our
world in a big way.
Today we are announcing the
next generation of Firebase
to help you build your app, grow
your user base, and earn money.
We're really interested
to hear what you think,
and we can't wait to
see what you build next.
MALE SPEAKER: VR is about
what you can experience.
Daydream is our platform
for high quality
mobile virtual reality to
create incredible immersive VR
experiences.
MALE SPEAKER: Things
previously thought
to be impossible may
in fact be possible.
We look forward to building
this future together
with all of you.
Thank you for joining
us at Google I/O.